[Applause]
so now to kick off our carnivorous
culinary adventure
chef restaurateur and cookbook author
please welcome
the incredible marcus samuel i'm so
excited to be here
it's weekly yes it is we need we need to
go back to meat with it
let's do this so this good old pork chop
is from my book the rice
and it's inspired by my dear friend
patricia gonzalez
she was 17 years old when we started the
book and now she knows she's a star in
cooking
i mean i loved this recipe i was pouring
over it
and i was actually really excited to ask
you once the meat is cooked
how to let it rest yes when to cut it
because this is meat week i find
the resting and the and the cutting a
real art
it is the biggest i think the number one
issue that people makes with
with any type of meat to cut the meat
the the grill the meat the roasted meat
and then let's slice it right away
meat needs to rest so when it rests you
put it here on your cutting board you
can cover a little bit of
foil you know a chop like this should
probably rest for about
good seven or eight minutes and it's not
going to get cold and then you slice it
if you slice it too early
all the juice is going to fall on the
cutting board so you don't want to do
that so i have in my pan here
seared pork chop garlic and thyme i'm
going to add in some of my favorite
spices
to turmeric because you know it's good
and healthy
it's um it's medicine yes and then a
little bit of cumin and we're just gonna
we're just gonna pour that in and we're
gonna make the sauce with
coconut milk this is inspired from the
dominican republic
where you have the mashed potatoes in
dominican republic it's called mangu
but it's done with plantains isn't that
amazing i'm excited to learn plantains
because i am intimidated by
this super delicious all you have to do
yeah
add in that coconut milk yes yes yes can
i ask you a quick question
yeah you know what i'm going to do on
drew's border here this is what i'm
going to do
this is the drew border yes we did it
yes so that is plantain mash
that's going to go with this pork chop
oh my gosh marcus
it's um the
the spices are incredible and you know
also why i'm so excited today because a
project like the rice like we really
focus
on african-american chef black chef what
is black cooking in america today
so we feature 45 black chefs and
really it's all about the authorship of
american food
it's really about setting up the right
memories
and the right aspirations what 45
black chefs in the book that we talked
about their journey to american food
i'm so excited to add this to my
collection i have cookbook club
i'm an avid collector and you know what
look at the salsa i'm adding yeah adding
a little bit tomatoes into that yes
there you go
add in also some bacon and crab because
when you have pork add more pork
that's the bacon great and then we're
just gonna mix this sauce
up with a little bit of crab to just get
that beautiful
flavor and texture and umami and i'm
gonna pour this
on top or just around it so i'm just
have
i got my my pork chop is ready i'm just
gonna let it
put a little bit of parsley in cilantro
but what is this dish called
so this is good old pork chop with mango
and the mango is the mashed
beautiful plantains that we have over
here you know also why i'm super excited
today today is a big day
in my world you know what today we
launching black business
matters matching fun it is a huge deal
and i'm partnering with lubri and
together we're driving businesses to
these incredible
black food entrepreneurs and uh we're
going to raise a lot of money
for all these businesses that's so
deserving kovat has hit our businesses
really really hard
particularly african-american businesses
so to be able to drive business and
money
and grants it's pretty amazing well i
was so
inspired by hearing that and we
want to donate five thousand dollars for
the fun
to help support black owned businesses
and restaurants
and then i'm gonna match that so it's
ten thousand dollars you are the best do
you know what i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna show how beautiful brew
cooked our beautiful pork chop oh thank
you i sliced it up for you
oh it's so beautiful here's your here's
your four
thank you mark and now we're gonna try
to do this awkward thing about eating
pretty on television well as there's
by the way i don't eat pretty at home
[Applause]
oh my gosh this has the perfect amount
of brightness and acid
yes it's so beautiful it's like
sunshine and yet
it's very hearty but it doesn't feel
too heavy really good and that pork is
perfectly cooked it's the coconut milk
that's the turmeric
and this dish and this book is so
meaningful and so important
and thank you for bringing with uber
eats the attention and the spotlight on
the program you're doing we're going to
have it on the drewberrymore show.com
so that you can go and participate
donate if you'd like but just
most importantly be made aware of this
very very important endeavor
and then also be sure to pick up a copy
of the rise black cooks and the soul of
american food
thank you